hello
everyone I'm very excited to introduce U
udar he's a machine learning science um
at
book.com and he'll talk about U
recommendation system of evaluation
thank you R you can yeah thank you thank
you hello everyone my name is Zar and
today I'm going to talk about
recommendation systems evaluation and
andit AB testing approach with insights
from
industry why I am going to talk about it
so I worked in different companies where
we try to implement recommendation
systems and I noticed the same problem
in each company so it's uh difficult to
evaluate offline and online effect and
reduce the gap between offline and
online evaluation
and today we start with overview of
recommendation systems after this we
talk a little bit about difference
between offline evaluation and online
and how to reduce the gap between
offline and online metrics I'm sure that
everyone knows how recommendation
systems works but let's try to do a
little introduction to recommendation
systems
so first questions is where can we use
the recommendation systems and short
answer that we can use this in any place
it could be streaming platforms travel
flights like
booking e-commerce or Media or social
network
everything and each business domain
requires specific approach and specific
recommendation systems model but of
course we can make some structure of our
exist
models of course we remember about
collaborative filtering this approach
based on Matrix interactions between
users and items uh and we can build
vectors for users and for items and try
and find Sim similar items for users or
similar users for
item and one approach is when we use all
Matrix another approach when we make the
compies the compies our Matrix for two
Matrix one Matrix is with latent user
vectors another Matrix is this with item
vectors the second approach is that
content based filtering model so it's
close is similar with
classical classification problem we un
user features item features and we try
to predict Target like Zer or one and
one means that it's positive feedback
from user and zero is negative or
nothing but uh State ofthe art in the
market in the industry is a hybrid model
where we combine previous approaches so
usually we use user features item
features
and embeddings uh output from simple
models from first level models and we
build the second layer of model and some
company in
Industry uh make more layers for example
they can use five 10 layers of models
where each model generates candidates
for second for second model second model
generates that for third model and it
could be very complex lexity
systems uh why I talking about this so
we can notice that recommendation
systems in comparison of classical
machine learning could be very complex
systems it means that we have gap
between offline and online metrics and
we need to be careful with evaluation
these systems and it is a questions how
to do these right
evaluations of course in recommendation
systems area we can measure different
metrics different offline metrics it
could be regression Matrix if we try to
predict rank it could be accuracy Matrix
if we try to evaluate the quality of the
top end recommendations in terms of
binary classification but of course
usually we use ranking metrics we
evaluate try to
evaluate the quality of the top end
recommendations taking into account
positions it's for example mean average
Precision or ndcg or something like this
but another questions in recommendation
systems that if we use only regression
accuracy or rting metrics is not enough
also we need to think about Beyond
accuracy metrics so this type of metrics
helps us toate recommendations in term
of user experience for example we can
measure we need to measure diversity in
our recommendation list we need to
measure novelty for example if you
Spotify uh and try to predict which
music you want to listen so you need
usually to use more new items or for
example if you're offline retail or
online retail probably it's better to
recommend you your previous items
and also uh and we have exist Trends
where we also need to evaluate bias in
our
recommendations and also we need to
measure stability of our recommendation
systems
and we have questions what is the right
metric so I don't have answ for these
questions because it depends it always
depends on business domain on business
area is is the key we need to choose one
of the list one one metric from our
lists and try to use this metric as a
proxy for our online metrics and it
depends on your domains how to choose
this
metric uh okay imagine that we build
complex recommendation system pipeline
we choose offline metric we measure
Beyond accuracy metrics like like d
diversity or
novelty but still how choose relevant
online metrics to evaluate our effect
our business
effect we can start again that this
metrics depends on business area for
example I work in fintech and the main
metric was registration of applications
or convers conversion in the applying
credit
cards and even in TR inside travel like
booking we have different type of
metrics for flights and for
accommodations it depends on
domain and also of course of in uh
majority time majority times we use
quantitative analysis so we choose
relevant business metrics to measure our
business effect and after this usually
we run a experiment but I want to
describe then this time we focus only on
the short CH metrics so because uh our
resources is limited and we cannot
measure long-term effects and this
reason also it's very useful trick in
Industry which can help before AB test
you need to do product analysis what
does it mean so we need to uh understand
our customer we need to do customer
development user studies experiments for
example what is the more important for
our customers to make our
recommendations more diversity to get
Discovery experience or to get novelty
experience or we can recommend only poal
items and it it will be
enough and we need to do this
analysis uh using customer development
for example and it helps us to focus on
the longterm effects sometimes it could
be even even better than AB test but I
think that we need to do it
together okay we choose short ter metric
uh it could be conversion rate
or or something like this but also we
need to think about threshold between
shortterm and long-term metrics of
course every business wants to increase
longterm metrics like lifetime value if
I talk about streaming service or amount
of
subscribers but we can not do a test
experiment because it takes one year and
again we need to try to find Optimal
threshold between amount of data
experiment duration and value of a
product okay for example we found this
threshold but another problem which we
can have so it's the novelty effect
usually in recommendation systems you
have one type of algorithm it's it's our
old machine learning
algorithm and we for example start to
recommend clickbait uh items in our
streaming service of course in the
beginning and even during beginning of
ab test we can notice incre increment
value in terms of our business metrics
but if we wait two 3 months uh this
effect could be decreased because in the
beginning of course our users likes the
novelty things likees the
novelty uh recommendation systems list
but after this they want to get more
experience
but I have two key how to solve these
problems so the first key that we need
to use specific metric for for each
segment of users in the recommendation
systems area it could be three group of
users hot users cold users warm users
and for example for hot users we need to
increase retention metrics because we
want uh that our user
return in our service and spend more
time in our service but in the same time
for cold users we can increase
conversion rate uh conversion metrics
like
CTR because we want to involve our users
in our
service the the second key that we need
to build hierarchy of metrics so it's
the main trick from industry is if we
build hierarchy of metrics it could be
very useful for us it should be one
primary business metric and uh we need
to decompose this metric for
submatrix and you and use each submetric
for specific segment for example it is
an example of hierarchy of metrics in
the streaming service like
Netflix and we need to uh use this
to understand how we affect our systems
using our machine learning
models but still for example we build
this hierarchy of metrics for example we
use offline and online
metrics but we still have a gap between
online and offline
Matrix and uh if we talk about how to
reduce this
Gap short answer uh we can do nothing
but long answer is that we have several
options first options we can testing our
systems in production and for example if
the new model does not decrease majority
of line
Matrix but for example our favorite
ofline metrix increase we can run
production and see what happens also we
can use R proxy experiment like inter
living experiment which we described in
the previous article from
booking.com also we can using we can use
multi bandies framework to decrease this
effect but the secret key that we can
also predict AB test Matrix based on
offline Matrix or try to find
correlations between offline and online
what does it mean uh so probably we can
log of our AB testing history and
collect this history and try to find
correlations and of course how I say
before so we need to use product
analysis and try to build hierarchy of
metrics is it the main difference if we
compare this this array recommendation
systems or ranking area with other area
like classical machine learning
and usually I noticed in different
companies that researchers use the naive
solution not all of this but 70% so they
monitor favorite of line metrics like
Rocka precision and DG and look for this
combinations ofline metrics they
increase offline metrics and they hope
that online metrix uh will increase too
but it didn't work well
the smart solution is that we logging
our offline metric and online metric of
the ab tests building stable
infrastructure using general training
and validation Pipeline and after this
we can try we can try to find
correlations between offline Matrix and
online
matrix it's not the key but it could be
help us to uh
decrease problems uh with this
Gap but still another problem where we
try to build this systems which try to
decrease reduce the gap between offline
and online is a feedback loop problem
and recommendation systems what does it
mean we learn our model we train our
model on data which has a
Bas because this history also was was
output from previous model model and
there is a loop it means that we we
don't have right offline Matrix because
we try to predict our offline history
which is also output from previous
models but but of course for this we
also have a Solutions we can use Global
control group to reduce this effects we
can use multi AR
bands and more complex Solutions but I I
only want to share these links for this
and it's
all in this summary I want to say that
in recommendation systems we need to
choose the right combination of offline
metrics that will be our proxy for the
main online metrix and I wanted to say
that it's more important than even than
choose right models choosing right
offline Matrix is more important
also uh if we want to increase Val Val
for your product step by step you need
to build hierarchy of the online
metrics choose right balance between
short term and long chm
effects and uh try to test this
hypothesis VI AB test but again remember
about novelty effect remember about
feedback loop
effect and still we will have the gap
between online and offline metrics
so and this problem is the most
challenging issue in recommendation
systems of course if if we can solve
this we can build model increase money
and it's all but it's not
true but we can
reduce uh this problem how we need to
build stable machine learning pipeline
we need to build stable AB test anline
evaluation schema and next step we can
try to find correlation between online
and offline
metrics thank you for your
attention